see kids don't always need magic wands
to be badasses sometimes phaser guns
work just fine and tactical intelligence
it's really more that Ender's Game
so Ender's Game is the movie adaptation
of the acclaimed book Ender's Game I
haven't read the book I'm just letting
you know this entire review will be to
the eyes of a guy who has not read the
Ender's Game book why because at this
point in life if I had read the Ender's
Game book I will have read it for the
sake of reading it before the movie
comes out every time I do that I end up
getting disappointed with the movies and
it pisses me off I wanted to review this
movie as a movie not a comparison to the
book that would just ruin the movie for
me you probably read the book now though
that'd be cool so the plot of Ender's
Game is some years ago these aliens
wiped out a lot of mankind this one
commander was like you know what I'm
gonna sacrifice myself and take out
those dickbags so now Harrison Ford and
a crew of people are like we need to
recreate a commander like that we're
gonna do it with children because you
can mold a soldier from a child easier
than you can with an adult because kids
are like sponges they just soak
everything else why you shouldn't cuss
around your children to let them watch
violent movies and play violent video
games you set mortal combat that's fine
because it didn't mess me up I guess so
the last best hope of mankind is ender
so now we have a movie about a bunch of
kids in a bootcamp school it's like if
Harry Potter and a Starship Troopers
movie that you could take seriously had
a kid together and I really enjoyed
Ender's Game first of all ender is an
awesome character and there's a badass
he's really smart I just like the way
the movie conveyed how he sees the world
everything's tactical everything's a
strategy and it really beats over your
head a really good point and that is a
good leader is not someone who leads
with negative reinforcement positive
reinforcement be that beacon that makes
her crew feel like they're actually a
really good crew don't be a [ __ ] and
you're smart he's strong he's wise he is
mentally years beyond with his physical
ages but he's also vulnerable and human
I just I really like the character ender
I want her to quote about humbleness and
it was humbleness is the ability to walk
shoulder-to-shoulder with anyone and not
make anyone feel like they're less that
is ender oh don't get me wrong he's not
a [ __ ] he won't take [ __ ] I'm just
saying don't be a dick to the kid
because he's smarter than you and he'll
do that whole cool Sherlock Holmes fight
you thing and win because he's smart
there's this one kid commander in the
movies a total dick to enter and you're
like yeah they're illustrating Napoleon
complex with this cake gotta crack me up
kids alike hey what are you doing it was
a douchebag I wanted ender to just shoot
him out of an airlock in that most of
the movie is kids in boot camp it's kids
training its kids in commander school so
you're like alright so it's not really a
war going on it's just a lot of training
I enjoy seeing training I like seeing
people become better become more so I
enjoyed this movie people who are
looking for an all-out galactic war
might be a little pissed and Games 2 is
really cool seeing them play these games
is that this game that they play it's
pretty much like blitzball from Final
Fantasy 10 meets laser tag with no balls
it's not pretty much that it's exactly
that and was cool the game was awesome
any time you'd see a thing in a movie
that makes me go I wish we had that
that's not a bad thing this movie did
that for me on the negative though there
are things that are clearly shoehorned
into this movie so the audience knows
how ender would react in a certain
situation you get the feeling they
covered this in a couple of chapters in
the book but the movie can't be six
hours long so you have two minutes to
illustrate to the audience at this point
of how ender is go that and a couple of
the emotional situations in this movie
that could have been great aren't as
great as they could have been there's a
scene that comes to my mind is ender has
grown as a soldier he gains the respect
of someone and you're like all right I
guess he did I don't care as much as I
should and it is kind of irritating
however the acting in this movie kicks
ass his kid who plays ender is a badass
Harrison Ford was really good Viola
Davis was awesome her and Harrison Ford
worked well together Ben Kingsley was
good in the movie for the short time
he's in the movie Ender's Game was a
great movie about growth and does the
end justify the means a couple of scenes
felt like they were a little rushed a
couple of emotional moments were not as
emotional as they should have been
however the movie kicks ass in the end
of this movie is awesome like you walk
out of this movie thinking about the and
you're like that was really cool and I
will say Ender's Game is worth buying on
blu-ray it got me interested to read the
books you know how you walk out of some
movie adaptations that are based off of
books and you're like I don't care to
read the book I don't I'm indifferent
not Ender's Game I actually do want to
find time to read that book as soon as I
beat Arkham origins and then go back and
beat Grand Theft Auto 5 there's no free
time so for you guys what is your
favorite movie adaptation of a book
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more